Hey everyone! In this video we'll take a look at some of the limitations of translucent materials
using Lumen and how we can avoid them to recreate a realistic look that we want.
We'll also be exploring some advanced techniques for edge control in the engine.
Let's get started!
Alright, as I just mentioned, we'll be reviewing how certain looks and feels can still be
replicated in engine without the use of the Fresnel node, using something like the dot product,
the power, and the transform vector node.
And knowing alternatives to the Fresnel index workflow that we just learned in the previous
class is really important because view-dependent effects like edge highlighting and transparency
calculations may not really receive proper dynamic lighting using Lumen.
We'll also get an overview on faking caustics and hot spots in Unreal without the use of
something called Path Tracer.
Because translucent reflections and materials aren't really properly captured in Lumen,
so for example they don't really contribute to light bounces onto other surfaces
and can really cast proper shadows.
So let's jump into the engine and see how we can still achieve what we want.
Okay, we're in the faking details and refraction area of our default map.
And if I navigate here and focus on the floor,
you can see this faking refraction kind of effect.
Now, it's important to acknowledge that without Path Tracer,
you cannot really get bounce lights like this on translucent materials.
But we can fake this using something called Decal Components,
with a specific texture assigned to them replicating this caustics or refracted look.
And if I press G and select my Decal Component, you can see what I mean.
Now, Decal Components are really just planes with translucent or additive blend modes
that wrap around surfaces like this
and are typically used to add details to our environments.
Now, let's select our Decal Component over here
and double click on its material to see how it was made.
Okay, so it might look a little bit messy, but this material is actually pretty simple.
First of all, let's acknowledge if we click in an empty area of the graph
that the material domain was changed from surface to deferred decal,
and the blend mode assigned is the translucent.
So in this material, we're really just taking a simple texture
that I'm gonna be opening up down here
that can be easily hand painted in any image editing software.
And then if I switch the preview mode to plane,
you can see how if applied to plane and then onto a surface,
it can easily recreate this refracted look.
Now, we have a linear gradient node here
that is attached to an add node that is not connected to anything.
We left it here just for you to play around
and you can connect it to any of the material properties.
We're done multiplying the base color with a really high value
to increase the emission of our decal.
And we have various values here that you can really play around with.
Now, keep in mind that decals materials
are much more limited than standard materials
because they're projected onto existing surfaces
rather than being full materials themselves.
So they don't really have any physical properties
and have very limited blend modes.
So you won't be able to push this in all the directions you want,
but everything in here is at your disposal to test things out.
All right, let's go back to our viewport.
And if we navigate more here on the right,
we can see some examples of using the power and dot node
to replicate the Fresnel effect.
Now, these two materials are not translucent
and they don't have any altered refraction index.
They're also not using any Fresnel nodes.
And yet they do replicate how the light would bounce
on surfaces such as silk in the first example, and cotton.
So let's select the first preview mesh
and then open up its material from the Details panel
to see how these materials were developed.
Okay, so this material is a bit more complex
than the simple decal we just examined.
And we'll just go over it together
because we're introducing some new nodes here.
So we're starting with a camera vector
that I'm just going to be plugging directly into the base color
to show you what it does.
I'll just be expanding this preview a little bit.
Okay, so the camera vector tells us the direction
of the camera from any point on our material surface.
And that's what you see here in this color information.
The camera vector is super useful for creating effects
that change based on the viewing angle
like the Fresnel effect that we're trying to recreate here.
Now, it's important to know that the camera vector
outputs a direction vector in world space.
And we're using this dot product to compare it
with another kind of information.
And if we follow the noodle down here,
you can see that this dot product
is connected to a transform vector,
which is connected to a texture sample
that has a black normal texture.
If I connect the RGB output of our normal
to the base color,
you can see that the color information displayed
is completely different from the camera vector.
And that's because normal maps are usually stored
in tangent space,
while camera vectors, as I just mentioned,
speak in world space.
So these two different color informations
are basically asking two different questions.
The tangent space normal map is asking,
what is the app vector for a specific point on the surface?
While the world space direction vector
of the camera vector is asking,
what is the app vector for the entire world?
So basically, the normal map is speaking
from an object point of view,
is object oriented,
while the camera vector is world oriented.
And that's where this transform vector node
comes into place.
Because if we click on this arrow here,
we can expand it,
and we can see that it's basically translating
the tangent space color information
into the world space,
so that these two nodes can speak the same language.
So if I connect the transform vector to the base color,
we can see here that the color information
is much more similar to the camera vector one.
Now, if we connect the dot product
to the output base color of our material,
we can see here what's going on.
So connected to the camera vector
and the transform vector,
the dot product is asking us,
how directly am I looking at this surface?
Because if I'm looking straight at it,
I will be resulting a value of one,
while if I'm looking at it from the side,
I will be resulting a value of zero.
This resulting into a black edge outline
and an inner white color.
Now, to recreate something like the cotton,
we want to invert this result
by using a one minus node,
and make the edge much more defined and fuzzy.
So if I connected this add node to the base color,
you can see what I mean.
Now, the cotton and the silk
are almost opposite in what they want to achieve.
What I mean by that is that, as you can see,
the one minus node is used for the cotton,
but it's not used with the silk.
And we can actually play around with these values
and invert them to have a really cool effect.
So if I switch these 20s to zeros,
and these zeros to 20s,
we have something like an inverted eye
that's constantly staring at us.
Let's make it a real eye.
So if after the add node,
I add a one minus node,
we'll basically invert the entire polar result.
And here we have a pupil constantly staring at us,
which I think is pretty cool,
and I wanted to show you that.
All right, that was it for this video.
I hope you had a good time.
In the next video,
we'll learn how to develop a bump offset effect
on a translucent material
and dive deeper into the bump offset workflows and techniques.
I'll see you there.